I'll start my diagram with the last commit that the coin branch has in
common with the master branch.
As you can see that's the revert controls commit here.
I use an ellipses to indicate there's more history off over here.
After this commit our history branches off into the master branch and
the coin branch.
So I'll split off here, keeping the master branch straight.
Each of these two branches has several more commits.
I'll label the last commit made on
each branch with the appropriate branch label.
Now remember, we also made a new branch off of master called easy mode, and
made one commit on it.
So we'll add that to the diagram as well.